hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong my name is mark
ellis on location from seattle
washington this is where remember my
family lives and so i'm here hanging out
for the week and if you're watching this
on any of our streaming services that we
partner with you'll see in the
background a painting that my grandpa
did that is the jersey devil jacqueline
coley my esteemed co-host you're looking
at the jersey devil how cool is that i
just like the fact that we're looking at
like mark ellis's entire lineage in the
background i see kids pictures like this
this is taking a peek behind the curtain
ladies and gentlemen deep into his
subconscious this is uncle mark in his
finest
yeah well it's sort of like what my life
could have been if i pursued a different
path and so i'm very happy pursuing the
path that i did pursue because it led me
up to seattle also to do stand up so
thank you to everybody that came to see
me at el corazon and that actually ties
in with the movie we're talking about
today because after the show did a big
show by the way that venue first time
pearl jam ever set foot on stage was at
that venue and then years later this
idiot so then we did the meet and greet
afterwards and there's a bar set up and
jacqueline i'm telling you i should have
taken a picture the bar looked exactly
like the bar in suicide squad where
they're all sitting around
regrouping getting ready for that third
act that i maybe i'm not the biggest fan
of but hey that's what we're talking
about today the oscar-winning film
suicide squad directed by david a or
starring a host of great actors and also
one uh lizard crocodile alligator person
the movie came out in 2016. 26 percent
rotten on the tomato
26 percent the audience score almost got
to fresh territory
tapping out at 59
so just one more percent just one more
audience
score it could have gotten to fresh but
it is a rotten movie according to the
tomato meter and so we're obviously
excited about james gunn's the suicide
squad which is coming out i believe
tomorrow is when that movie comes out in
theaters so a whole lot of excitement in
the world of comic book movies right now
but jacqueline coley we have a very
special guest today and she is not only
one of the founding members of the world
girls she not only does a daily show
that she started in the pandemic and she
literally shows up every day to do live
at the roxy and speaking of movies she
has a really cool film project that she
is going to be i believe on location for
a number of weeks after this recording
she's hopping on a jet plane so we have
her now she is the one the only one of
my dear friends miss roxy streier hello
miss streier are we still woo people
anymore i know i mean kovit's back let's
bring wu's back yeah i'm thinking
i'm just always been a woo girl
now i don't know what's cool anymore
it's still strange but
i'm here uh and i'm so
so happy that you guys let me on for
this episode i can't even explain to you
how much i want to talk about this today
i can't explain it like
think this is a gift to me this is like
a late birthday present to me
hey this is you know you you had a big
birthday recently so he wanted to spoil
you and as the world girl gives willing
a world now we get to hear your thoughts
first on suicide squad so roxy just
quickly tell me if rotten tomatoes is
right or wrong when it comes to suicide
squad with that 26 rotten this is the
i ca i can't even preface i have to just
get to it this is the most wrong rotten
tomatoes has ever been about any movie
ever that ever existed i cannot believe
how rotten rotten tomatoes thinks that
this movie is
when it's
incredible i am such a fan of suicide
squad because
i
lack any ability to to
care about anything other than did i
enjoy myself and oh my god every time i
watch this movie i enjoy myself so much
it has
it's the least pretentious movie it is
so weird it at times fine doesn't make
sense it has a hodgepodge of motley crew
characters that are
on some scale of
meh to amazing but together everything
all combined this movie is so much fun
and that's all i care about it's all i
care about it is one of the most
entertaining dc films if not comic book
films ever
and all that plus harley
plus will smith i mean what what more
were people wanting from this film
i don't understand i don't get what
movie people were watching 20
somebody pissed in somebody's cereal and
they were not happy about this film but
not me i had milk that day
oh i'm i'm glad your wheaties were
kosher i mean
roxy you take a look at this movie and
we're gonna get all the scene break down
and what we loved about it what maybe we
didn't love about it and there's a lot
to digest with the behind the scenes the
making of this movie so we'll get to
that a little bit later on in the show
too so roxy i'm going to need your
number what what number you think this
movie should be but before we get to
that i will turn it over to my esteemed
co-host for a synopsis of suicide squad
jacqueline coley what the hell is this
movie about
yes ladies and gentlemen let's go back
to 2016
and the suicide squad because this is
what we have here we've got david ayers
bringing together a cast of characters
that includes deadshot played by will
smith harley quinn played by margot
robbie uh captain boomerang played by
jai courtney and jay hernandez playing
the fire demon i mean these are the bad
guys as they like to say and viola davis
as amanda waller has put all of these
cast of characters together and said you
guys are out there to go save the world
it's called project x because she thinks
hey what if the next superman is a bad
guy we may need some bad guys to help
solve it so they bring in the dirty
dozen or half dozen in this case i guess
they get to go save the world and the
person they're trying to battle in this
is played by cara devine and she plays
enchantress she is a
ancient being that is trying to take
over the world with
space lasers things that you know she's
gonna make a weapon to end the world and
they go save the world there's lots of
music
lots of music
a little bit of superhero stuff and uh
the joker pops up yeah jacqueline i i
didn't hear that did you say that
there's music in the movie oh my god
yeah it's amazingly you can barely tell
that they have some musical cues you got
to look for it yeah but you got but if
you listen hard you can you can hear it
no this movie this is
a music video with superhero elements
okay that that's a very fair synopsis
and i i feel bad for any insurance agent
in the greater city of chicago because
man did that city get wrecked at the
third act of this movie and maybe the
movie itself got a little wrecked by the
third act so we're gonna talk about all
this but first hey producer lucy's here
hi lucy
hello i was engrossed in that synopsis
took me a while to unmute myself how's
it going
how's it going everyone we're thrilled
to be joined by you do you have thoughts
on suicide squad are you excited about
the new one i'm very excited about the
new one i love james gunn who did
guardians and i
i loved guardians number one so i'm
curious to see
i'm a little nervous that he's just like
redoing it
for dc but hopefully there's a fresh
thing going on but yeah i love ensemble
films i'm very excited this is certainly
one of them so 2016 suicide squad
directed by david ayer roxy now we get
to hear you clearly think rotten
tomatoes is wrong with your impassioned
speech at the top of the show what
number
on the tomato meter should suicide squad
be are you going high are you going 80s
are you going 90s this not only should
be double and not only triple what the
score is but yeah i put this at an
actual 80.
an 8-0
is it the best movie i've ever seen in
my life you know that's in the 98
territory no
but are we calling this a c movie in the
70s only if you're
only if you hate
life and fun and all the good things in
our because you don't understand movies
you don't understand you don't you don't
want to enjoy yourself eat your popcorn
enjoy your movie thank you for noticing
jaclyn that this is a music video
and a movie at the same time
that's what i've wanted my whole life
music me
yes roxy's got the roxy gets it to a b
minus where if it was triple its score
it would have been 78 percent that's
like a high c that's like a mark l is
college grade jacqueline coley what do
you think this should be do you agree
with our incredible guest
10
10
out of 10
out of 100
this is gonna be so much fun today
i'm really gonna try like and i give
five for will
i give actually you know what i get four
for will because he had to show his face
all the time i give five for harley
quinn and i give one for jay courtney
what did i do
what did i do to you jaclyn
nothing i mean look i am not even like
we'll get into this about me and suicide
squad in dc
but
it's it's gonna be so interesting for me
to break down with this because i've
lost all emotion when it comes to this
franchise to these filmmakers to this
film if you would have spoken to me back
in 2017-18
i would have had so much fury and anger
at the disappointment that this film was
for me and now i can just look at it
with mild amusement to be like oh i'm so
sorry you all had to make that
and made it they did but was it the
version that the director that the stars
thought they were getting when it was
released we get to talk about all of
that stuff i personally think rotten
tomatoes is wrong on this i think 26
is too low i i didn't love this movie i
actually agree with what the audience
scored this movie is so i think like
that
55 to i'll go 59 i'll put it right there
on the spaceballs number where it is so
so so close to being fresh that's where
i think this movie belongs because i
really loved a lot in this movie but man
did once enchanter shows up i just lost
everything that i was enjoying about
that movie for the duration pretty early
mark that's pretty early when she shows
up and like we're actually battling her
and we're not just having fun with our
various music themes and introducing
characters anymore oh we are going to
talk about suicide squad in just a sec
but right now we have one of my favorite
segments because it gives us a break and
we turn it over to tim ryan our expert
review curation manager here at rotten
tomatoes for two minutes with tim
[Music]
after batman v superman was criticized
for being too grim there were hopes that
suicide squad would lighten things up a
little bit within the dc eu
but the result according to critics was
the mishmash with too many characters
too many wise cracks and not enough
coherent storytelling it's a 26 on the
tomato meter with 385 reviews and it has
a 59 audience score so what do the
critics have to say in a rotten review
todd mccarthy of the hollywood reporter
wrote a puzzlingly confused undertaking
that never becomes as cool as it thinks
it is suicide squad assembles an
all-star team of super villains and then
doesn't know what to do with them
however in a fresh review tony hicks of
the san jose mercury news wrote it will
be interesting to see where dc takes
these characters after the
semi-delightful mess that is suicide
squad but for now just enjoy the sloppy
and wild ride ron tomato's critic's
consensus reads suicide squad boasts a
talented cast and a little more humor
than previous dceu efforts but they
aren't enough to save the disappointing
end result from a muddled plot thinly
written characters and choppy directing
so that's suicide squad and don't forget
mark and jaclyn are the bad guys
wait are you you're the good guys
i'm confused
let's move on we're the bad guy we're
not the worst and so that's why they got
us out of prison and put that chip in us
so that we can do a podcast every week
because again we're not the worst so
let's kick it off let's get right into
movie talk let's talk about first of all
the trailer let's talk about the scenes
that we love the scenes that
disappointed us who the standout in the
movie was all that stuff coming up right
now
[Music]
yeah there was a lot of excitement for
this movie and
going back and watching the trailers you
notice a slightly different tone with
each ensuing trailer but roxy was this a
movie that you had a lot of hype for
like going in did you know a lot about
the property was this like you're
pinning your summer movie hopes on this
movie
yeah absolutely at the time i was
hosting dc movie news so i was so in the
dc world it was like somebody would chip
a tooth and we would talk about it for
two hours during a show so at this point
going into suicide squad i was full
blown in that world and so the hype was
real for me and then i think like
everybody else on the planet after
watching that trailer the hype just got
more real people thought that this was
going to be
just the bee's knees an expression that
i have not used since 1947 i guess i
should have
thought it kept it there
be amazing people thought that this
movie was going to be just so great i
don't know when other people got off
that wagon i just stayed on that train
but yeah i was so so excited about this
we've heard rumblings about what was
going on
behind the scenes on set and there
in the age of social media we were
getting tons of different posts about
this
definitely definitely was going into
this thinking wow i'm about to be blown
away but it had no pressure on it at the
same time because we weren't getting
superman or batman or wonder woman or
flash or aquaman you know these
characters that people have such
attachments to a lot of these characters
what people were seeing for the first
time in live action and so i thought
that they were going to be able to play
and have fun yeah and that was the big
thing jacqueline i you were probably
like working at comic con doing actual
things and i was just in hall h and
david ayer came on stage and this is a
few weeks before suicide squad comes out
and the big selling point of this movie
was like hey marvel we know they're
doing great things but they don't have
great villains we have all these cool
villains in one movie and they're all
going to team up and so i was pretty
excited to see what suicide squad was i
don't know what your hype level was but
is it what was it anywhere near the
anticipation that roxy had for this or
were you already done by then
no i was so hyped for this movie i
remember
following the casting news so intently
and the reason why i was so hyped is i
might add what warner brothers has not
been able to really do with their live
action i have to say that their animated
features by and large are absolutely
incredible and i've seen all of them and
there is this great animated feature
about the suicide squad called assault
on arkham it had deadshot it had harley
quinn it's almost the exact same
storyline of this one but it was
actually coherent and done well and i
thought if nothing else if they just
refilm that with will smith and margot
robbie like the biggest worry i had
going into this movie was like jai
courtney who was like the guy that kept
showing up in all these movies and like
we didn't really know what to make of
him like he was in the divergent series
and it was like okay there's a lot of
jai courtney happening but i don't
really know why he's such a thing
completely wrong with that he was
actually one of the better parts of this
film but yeah i was that was the biggest
worry i was like how can you mess it up
with will smith and margot robbie how
there's no way you could mess that up
right
they found a way so you have a new joker
and it's like oh well and and jared leto
we know how method he goes and so
there's just so much that we could get
we're hearing about stuff on the set
that we'll get into and behind the
scenes talk but i'm going to be selfish
right now and i'm just going to go ahead
and jump into my favorite scene one of
my favorite scenes in the whole movie is
the beginning that music video portion
that so many people were criticizing
after they saw it i thought it was so
necessary because you have an
introduction of a character and you have
their own sort of theme music that is
something from the pop culture lexicon
usually in the vein of rock but
occasionally they went out to different
places and different genres of music to
give you a sense of the character and i
loved it a because it's really fun to
watch like roxy said but it also i
thought was crucial because we don't
know these characters that well at least
i didn't i didn't read suicide squad i
barely heard of it before they announced
the movie and so i kind of needed some
sort of attitude which they used for
music to associate with these characters
just so i could have some sort of
working knowledge of who they were and
what they were about
[Music]
stay back
she moves fire up all right
[Music]
you gonna come down from there or what
yeah
look at you
so i thought the movie kicked off with a
bang how did y'all feel roxy were you a
fan of the way the movie kicked off like
i was i'm so with you because i think
that
at an end of the movie i don't like to
be spoon fed but at the beginning of the
movie i kind of do and this movie just
took me like the baby that i am and fed
me every single bite here are the
bullets here's the sound for this
character there's a lot of new
characters going on roxy can you keep
them all in order and i was sitting
there eating that up i was like yes
thank you please explain it all to me
and they were doing it in a way that was
fun and exciting and i just feel like at
that point they really had the audience
and and that was really fun for me
because then the audience started to
turn but at that moment in the beginning
everybody was still with them or at
least it felt that way i don't know if
jaclyn's on that page though jaclyn
fingers crossed no no i i i will admit
that this movie definitely jumped the
shark for me but the beginning the
montage let's get all the bad guys in
place that was done very very well
that was great character introductions
for the most part but i will say
when the movie falls apart is when the
character introductions fall apart
because the minute you introduce what's
his name it's like this is slipknot the
guy that can climb anything and i'm like
who the f is this guy he's he's
definitely a red shirt like i know he is
not making it to the end of this because
i have never heard of you you barely
made it into the trailer what is going
on first of all i also feel bad for that
actor i forget what his name is i'll
look it up in just a second but he was
like on the promotional tour and like
part of the like big junket and i'm like
how would you feel to be like i'm in the
movie for five minutes and people are
asking me like hours worth of questions
about this i would feel so stupid
but the minute he shows up and then by
the time we get to this is katana
she's got my back that was when i was
done i was like you know what this is
like we're done with character
introductions she's just here because
reasons like there's no point in having
her i was so over it and it was like
that was when freaking joel kinderman's
character rick flag became mr exposition
like that's all he did for the rest of
the movie was just tell us the things
that we maybe didn't know about like get
her heart
bubba i'm like oh my god and
so yeah the opening was great but that
that particular moment like from
slipknot and katana forward i was like
this thing
is a house of cards and and it was also
the music at that point became
oppressive
like the music that they had when they
were like kind of getting ready and like
harley quinn has the gratuitous sexual
assault camera video thing that they do
where she's wearing those booty shorts
and they just pan up for reasons that's
when i was like oh the music is to hide
the fact that nothing interesting is
happening really and they need to get
the audience excited and so they spent
like 80 million dollars on the music
budget so started to feel a little like
that yeah towards
towards the end of the movie i felt like
it was it was leaning a little too hard
into hey we need because like i i like a
big bombastic opening i'm a star wars
kid so i want to see a huge giant
opening that shuts the audience up right
away and gets us focused and locked in
the movie suicide squad achieved that
but yeah roxy i i i gotta agree with
jacqueline where like at some point of
the movie it's like now you got to be a
movie you know
you got to drop that facade by the way
adam beach played slipknot and was
totally underutilized in my opinion
because if you see him in flags of our
fathers he is tremendous and karen
fukuhara is katana and so i would have
liked to have seen more of them but
again we got a lot of characters we got
to sort through this stuff we got to
give will smith and margot robbie their
screen time i totally get that
the the person though that really stands
out in this movie to me
is viola davis as amanda waller because
there's very few performers that could
get me to buy into what we're doing here
we're going to bail all these people out
of jail and yeah we're going to keep an
eye on them we're going to keep a watch
on them we can chip them in any and and
bring him back at any time but
she just sold me so hard that this is a
good idea that this is what needs to
happen and i
thought she was far and away
the best character in the entire movie
and that's coming from a guy who
worships the ground that will smith
walks on so amanda waller gets it from
me roxy if you had to pick one scene or
one standout or both what is it if you
had to tell somebody hey this is the one
scene and the one character that i
really loved the most from suicide squad
what are you going with oh i have all of
those things mark i have i have 15
scenes and all the characters not all
the characters enchantress can fight
dust uh i i will say that viola is a
great pick and i think if your dc heart
beats as hard as mine does and you're as
nerdy as i do you watch all the cw tv
shows at the time and what had happened
in the cw shows was that they ripped
amanda waller right from the shows and
told us you actually can't have her
anymore uh because the movies are gonna
take amanda waller so the tv fans were
like but it's amanda waller how are you
gonna not have her in the dc shows where
is she gonna go so the
the expectations going into suicide
squad i was like she better bring it uh
and
jokes on me has viola ever not brought
in her entire life of course she did so
that's a really good pick on top of her
i definitely think that
it's the most basic answer i can give
but harley
harley i think that
if you watch this movie and you're a
harley quinn fan uh and i and i've been
a harley fan for long before this movie
and will be long after this movie
i was really excited by a lot of the
choices they made jaclyn you referenced
the pan up for some reason all the
harley stuff even the sexualized stuff
it just worked for me it feels like her
character it felt true to
what i have always off the page thought
of harley to be or in uh the animated
series especially in harley quinn's own
animated series which took place
obviously after this i think that they
did her justice she had a lot of really
great one-liners and her dynamic with
will smith was really what kept this
movie going for me in terms of favorite
scenes the bar scene
i know that that's the least
action-packed scene but i love that i
liked us taking a breather for one
second and then just kind of being like
where where are we at where's
everybody's heads at what's going on
okay let's readjust and let's move
forward i got letters from my daughter
the whole time
i'm gonna get you there
and you're gonna end this
i'm gonna carry your ass if i have to
this [ __ ] is gonna be like a chapter
in the bible
everybody's gonna know what we did
my daughter is gonna know that her daddy
unfortunately after that is where i
think a lot of people
really jumped off of the movie but in
that scene i feel like they captivated
us and we are really paying attention to
them yeah
that scene was so
weird to think about in retrospect
jacqueline because i love that bar scene
too you just get to actually watch them
connect as humans and you really could
feel the camaraderie however
the funhouse mirror like it had been
forged it felt real in that moment and
we were gearing up to go
do this battle against enchantress but
that battle just i thought was so poorly
executed from start to finish it totally
just took me i just didn't care about it
it's like i cared so much about them at
the bar scene and then i didn't care
about anybody for the rest of the movie
i just want to get the hell out of the
theater how does that change happen so
quick
i mean i think it happens when you write
the script in six weeks i mean look like
uh we'll get into this in the behind the
scenes but to david ayers defense i
don't feel
that
this movie this movie was sold on will
smith margot robbie jared leto viola
davis and they were just like we have
put together such a great cast we've got
to get this in theaters as quickly as
possible and so they just never gave
beats for these characters and it and
what's interesting though of it too is
that the only time the characters feel
lived and real is when they're not
fighting
all of the stuff that involves the fight
is where it falls apart when you have
will smith with his daughter
that feels real even harley quinn and
the joker falling in love those feel
real and it just seems like whenever it
was separated from the amanda waller
being devious
you know it's putting the cast of folks
together all of that felt real and lived
in but they could not translate that to
these people then saving the world which
i'm like i get it's a hard needle to
thread because they're anti-heroes
but
i just feel it could have been just
executed in an entirely different way i
will say this though as far as scenes
that i do like um and things that i do
like
i don't hate jared leto's joker and i
will tell you why i know a lot of people
have a lot of issues with jared letters
joke joker j leto's joker
the joker is a character that is very
difficult to reinvent and one of the
things that happened is
heath ledger had already done the joker
as real as you can get it
and have it still play true to the
character like if you met the joker he's
not going to be jack nicholson from the
tim burton thing that is more cartoonish
in a lot of ways you know what i'm
saying or romeo from like the 1960s if
you had a modern day joker he's going to
be exactly kind of what nolan showed in
that trilogy so to really reinvent it
you got to take some liberties and i
liked that they took the swing for the
fences on that character because he's a
very hard character i think to reinvent
so i appreciate that it took a swing for
offenses do i agree with everything like
the damage tattoo across his face maybe
not
but i do like like this underground
crime lord sort of thing i thought that
was a cool angle to sort of separate it
from the joker incarnations that we had
gotten leading up to because you had to
you had to go away from
that heath ledger joker and create some
sort of distance i'm curious for on your
thoughts roxy on on joker being in the
movie because there there's apparently
so much more that we could have seen
from joker that was cut out do you think
joker got enough screen time in the
movie because it didn't take away from
the actual squad would you like to see
less joker more joker where did you
stand on it i'm with jacqueline in the
sense that i'm one of the
people in the minority who actually
didn't dislike this joker there wasn't
enough for me to rave about him so i
can't sit here and say he was an amazing
joker but there also wasn't enough for
me to rag on him i thought that he kind
of understood the assignment and yeah
and was just following
what what are you gonna do if you do
have damage written on your forehead and
your hair is green and you are throwing
harley into the vat of acid and that is
your dialogue and
the amount of people who blame jared
leto for not liking his joker i don't
think understand how movie making works
because he didn't he didn't write it and
he didn't costume design himself and he
didn't he just i i thought his
performance was totally fine
yeah and and he just was kind of living
in what was created around him i also
liked some of the
joker harley stuff mostly because margot
robbie's so good
that you felt for her
you you're watching a extremely toxic
relationship which is the
at the core of joker and harley what
exists
and you believe what's going on because
of margot robbie's reactions and facial
expressions and movements and so i think
that that stuff kind of worked
in large part because of her
but also i thought he was fine would i
have liked to see more
in a different story in this story i
don't know that it would have made much
more sense to have joker in there a ton
more
yeah yep come on let me just
let me just say this though too just
because i don't want any of the
the joaquin phoenix joker heads to come
for me i am separating joaquin phoenix's
joker from that because as much as that
film is quote-unquote a joker movie it
is the king of comedy more than that
like i feel like that is definitely a
movie where they took the plot points
from something else and just put a skin
of superhero on top of it like if you
have you used that before no i'm not i'm
not but that's what it is so
yeah so like i just want to say that
it's not that it's bad i'm not like
trying to criticize that portrayal but
it is is in the comics and it borrows
obviously a lot from the comics but it
borrows a lot more from martin scorsese
it also hasn't happened yet yeah exactly
after this yes and it was after this but
i'm just saying in general like you know
people compared the fact that you know
heath ledger was able to do this joker
and then joaquin phoenix was able to
make another very realistic joker
joaquin phoenix made another realistic
travis bickle who just happened to laugh
absolutely yeah and i actually feel like
jared leto's joker it didn't move me one
way or another i thought it was the
proper amount of screen time so i know
he put a lot into the performance sorry
more of it didn't get in the movie i
thought that's what we needed from joker
because the thing i did i like having
joker in there not the least of which of
reasons is that we got to see one
sequence with batman quickly in it which
is awesome and
but but i don't want more joker in the
movie because i wanted this to be harley
quinn's grand
coming out party and i didn't want that
sullied by this clearly damaged
pun intended relationship that she has
with joker so i wanted it to be her
movie and her success less about that
relationship we want to get into that
relationship make that movie but that's
not what i saw suicide squad as being so
i thought the joker was properly
utilized and now i get to ask my
favorite question but it's also hard
because i really like roxy roxy you love
this movie you're a huge fan it was so
much fun is there
a least favorite character that you're
like
dude didn't really work for me yeah 100
and it's enchantress
that was that was a bunker
yeah
the the best part about enchantress was
the last five years in which i got to
make fun of the enchantress dance like
that is the best thing that happened
about enchantress
i
i
to me
i i hate to just drag somebody but cara
delevingne is a model
and is in came up as a model and
i don't think that this was 100 her
fault because also the way that it was
written and the design
and just so much riding on her but when
you are
when you have people
like viola davis and will smith and even
margot robbie at this point like that
are more vets and you are next to those
people and this is not where you are
trained
it just showed and it showed the entire
movie uh even when she is
what's her name june
june before she's enchantress yeah yeah
and both sides i was like oh girl this
is just not working no part of it's
working and
i think that
in this film in a lot of comic book
movies a lot of comic book movies suffer
because the villain is lacking
that's kind of why i'm confused on why
this movie gets as much heat as it does
because people seem to overlook that in
other comic book movies but not this one
but in this movie for sure the villain
is lacking and i think because of that
the third act is very obviously the
weakest
very weird like axel rose sort of dance
that she's doing towards the end and
it's just none of that worked i and i
actually like cara delevingne i thought
she was good in that uh with that paper
towns movie i that's pretty good in that
so yeah i mean that's what gave us
that's what gave us the string of her
doing big budgets because let me give
you what her run was right after paper
towns pan suicide squad and valerian the
city of a thousand planets
girl had a rough run there i have to get
rid of this
not not her fault i mean it was not her
fault but they paid 900 billion dollars
to make valerian but yeah you know that
that i agree with roxy i thought she was
the weakest part of the movie that
character was for me and that that end
fight scene when we're in some sort of
underground uh the you know system and
and we're just we just destroyed all
chicago and it just should have been
this really cool epic climax and i just
felt nothing do you have a different
pick jacqueline for like your least
favorite character the character that
you just could have kicked right out of
the movie i mean there's like it's hard
like
kinderman i like him i think he's great
character
uh actor um not but his like rick flag
why are you there what is scott eastman
uh eastwood doing in this like he looks
like he was so superfluous to everything
that that he was about um
yeah i think if we're gonna say
cringiest
character yeah rick flag and katana why
are you here
um
roxy took the best one with enchantress
so i will say that that is the one that
sticks out the most um but it's not even
cringy they're just like they're not
good i will say this though too um i
think you may be a friend of yours
because he's a comedian but ike the guy
that plays um the guard
give him some awards because that was
some great performing he absolutely
added a level of comedy to this that
didn't feel cringy whereas in some of
the other cringier aspects did i'll give
i'll give dialogue the cringy that's
what i will give you we're some sort of
suicide squad
i don't know if you know this but we're
the bad guys like that is what i give
the cringy factor so no one actor
definitely that's that dialogue uh
favorites for me obviously viola davis
and will smith but what surprised me is
that i found joel kinnaman and jai
courtney's characters i those guys just
never really like popped for me on
screen prior to this movie so i wasn't
expecting a lot from them but i actually
really dug both their characters and i
saw some personality there and i'm like
oh we can do this guy we can joel jai we
can do this so i was pleasantly
surprised by them again it just boils
down to that the third act completely
falling apart in such a way that i can't
even get this
this movie to fresh and now we have the
new suicide squad the suicide squad will
it win an oscar like the 2016 one did
for best makeup and hair styling i
believe is what it is also give it up
for the man from ove and i think it was
ah who's the other who was the other
oscar nominated for hair and makeup that
year like it sucks for you guys to lose
that year don't you feel
like if you take an l to suicide squad
at the oscars roxy that's gotta hurt a
little bit that's gotta hurt the reason
i don't feel that is because of all the
information we hear about like
killer croc having sitting in the chair
for five hours a day make sure you start
shooting you know yep yep if you're
losing to somebody who doesn't care and
you're there for 20 minutes and it's
just because it's a
a big movie a franchise movie that's one
thing but of all of the elements of this
movie
i think that that was a really strong
one they really gave a crap about that
the way this looked and sounded they
clearly cared about now actual story
i i hear some of your points some
of your points
i remembered who it was it's star trek
beyond if you're not telling me kroll
with idris elba or what's her name the
dancer girl um i can't think of her name
sophia boutrelle when she was the white
girl with the black stripes yeah
brutella
that could have beat this i'm sorry
killer croc is dope but idris elba
became an alien to a human over the
course of two and a half hours hey i
just you think about ottawa and as
killer croc in that makeup chair and you
just gotta
feel for that poor guy where it's like
dude a couple years ago you were in
hawaii filming lost just living it up
and now you're in a crocodile suit on
some god forsaken set with a movie that
is going to be very uh controversial
when it comes out as far as how people
feel about it and that's really our
thoughts on suicide squad the movie
itself so i want to get into the behind
the scenes i want to talk about the
david ayer and how he has sort of
changed his tune jared leto's very very
method acting and if we are excited
about james gunn's new version of the
suicide squad we're going to do all that
and more right now with behind the
scenes
david ayer came out on that stage at
comic con and he gave it was like a pep
talk to 6 000 people and it wasn't it
didn't feel desperate like hey we really
need to sell this movie it was like we
were all in a locker room and i was
ready to run for it through a brick wall
for that guy because he was just talking
about how excited he is and and he makes
gritty dirty movies i mean this guy did
end of watch this guy started his career
in hollywood as a screenwriter for u571
i mean
he knows how to do good great work and
and so i think that that was another
thing that just went to that
anticipation of it but now you have all
this stuff where he was playing the good
soldier up until the movie's release but
roxy the director himself just feels
like the studio completely raked his
movie over the coals did not
in any way shape or form or release the
cut that he wanted and now everybody
because they saw snyder's
cut of the justice league now they want
to see the air code of suicide squad
what would the air cut do for you do you
still hold out hope is is there any part
of you that says this movie could have
been better or do you think that the
studio sort of taking it from david
ayers grip made it the best possible
movie yeah i don't feel good about
loving something that the creator
doesn't love i i that does hurt my soul
a little bit
but i believe that if this had been
better received by the audience i don't
think we would have ever heard from air
that's kind of how these things go we
know nobody talks about the director's
cut when the studio made it better right
so
100 that and when things have uh 70 or
above on rotten tomatoes and the
audience is really happy with it we
never hear a director come out and say
but they didn't do what i wanted them to
do the directors kind of just say like
oh okay you guys liked it i think the
error mostly has spoken up because this
got
bashed uh not and not as much by the
audience and remembering that this made
three quarters of a billion dollars it's
not like this movie didn't bring in way
more money than the studio could have
expected on a suicide squad film with
characters that we had never seen before
so in that sense he did his job but i i
feel bad that he didn't get to show us
what he wanted to see i think that
i at ver at first when we had heard
about release the snyder cut i was like
how much could that really help
spoiler alert it really effing helped so
you never know you don't know what these
things do i want to see the haircut
in my heart of hearts yeah i do i do i'm
just kind of a curious person i don't
think that this should be the trend
these days where every time something
doesn't do well we release the blank cut
but the fact that david air has been
campaigning for this
and
there now it kind of doesn't really even
matter with the future of it i'm
interested
i'm curious i think sometimes it is
easier just to say hey this is what i
would have done and actually not have it
come out because apparently i mean he
was making a much darker movie than what
we got and i don't think that there was
as much gonna be as much humor and
probably not as much of a music video
feel and so if he makes an even darker
grittier sort of movie might be
interesting and maybe it pays off in the
third act better than it did with
enchantress the way that they went with
that
i i think sometimes it is just best to
let sleeping dogs lie especially when
you have the suicide squad coming out
but one of the interesting things about
him as a director is that he has some
very like sort of odd things that
according to the cast really helped them
bond
making this movie i mean some of the
cast
like they would share person very
personal stories about them like how
they became the person that they are and
then that was incorporated into it and
so like when roxie's talking about how
powerful that bar scene is i think a lot
of that is due to david a or in the the
bonding techniques that he had with the
cast leading up to
scenes like that there's a couple cast
members that got tattoos
too to solidify that they're in that
they're in the squad and then
jaclyn that also lends itself to well
some actors prepare differently than
others and
at jared leto uh man he uh he caused
some shenanigans on set didn't he
look i'm not gonna look everyone has
their process but i will tell you this
there's not a lot of poc method actors
because you know what you call a poc
method actor unemployed there is a
privilege
to be the type of person who sends a rat
to margot robbie or used condoms or
whatever thing else that he's like sent
to the cast members or like not speaking
to them as jared he re he required
people on set to refer to him as joker
like all of these things like i get it
especially when you look at some of the
method actors who have used that process
to achieve incredible things on screen
not trying to just dismiss anybody's
process but i'm just saying you have to
operate from a level of privilege to be
allowed to do the shenanigans that these
people were allowed to do
in the pursuit of their art that jack
and i'm totally with you i think in 20
in 2021 i actually kind of don't think
it would have flown yeah i i think that
this this came
one or two years
it it it like just slid in he just got
by
and i i don't know that it would have
been the same obviously it ended up
being bizarre too because if we were
talking about this like he's the
greatest joker of all time the
conversation around it might be
different but because people didn't
really love his joker and then they're
finding out he's sending the sticky
magazines
it's like
yeah
your method acting
didn't necessarily translate on screen
so now you're just sending sticky
magazines yeah i'm curious for your take
on that too roxy because you're about to
go on set to shoot a movie for a few
weeks which is very exciting would it be
less or more exciting if somebody who's
playing a villain in your movie sent you
a rat and to her credit margot robbie
had fun with it margot robbie it was a
live rat and she kept the rat alive she
used it as a pet she got like a wheel
for it and stuff so she had a pet rat
while she's making the movie but like if
if that's making you get in character is
that at the expense of the other actors
there's a rehearsal room story where a
bunch of them are rehearsing and then he
has a henchman drop off a dead hog and
just here he goes from joker and it's
like okay i'm glad you're getting into
character but roxy wouldn't that throw
any of us off our game i think the
dead animals would not throw me off if
i'm harley because i think that kind of
would help me get into character in some
ways but
but the used condoms
i think that that is where that's where
my personal line would be that's your
line i'm not trying to i'm not trying to
get those condoms in my dms and
certainly not on my doorstep yeah
also i might add though too on the whole
uh joker
thing one person who he did not do
anything to was viola davis like this
was like she actually spoke to the
impressor she was like nah he didn't
bring any of that smoke near me like
literally and i was like
that's because you're viola davis and
let's be honest even jared leto probably
knows better than to be like you know
what i mean like like he didn't he
didn't play that game with her at all um
also
when we were talking about the director
cut
let's be honest though the first
director who made the case for like i
didn't get to make my movie like
hardcore in the sort of modern superhero
age was actually josh trank
with his fantastic four which he
actually reviewed on letterbox and like
tweeted the opening weekend like i hope
you guys will eventually get to see the
movie i did which i also have to say
the directors that are able to do that
you're operating from a place of
privilege
like
not a lot of other directors could say
those things and still get a job and
work right and still work like i just
feel like people are not appreciating
the fact that
not everybody is allowed to tell their
truth and not be punished for it well
it's it sometimes it does come full
circle in hollywood and that's certainly
the case with james gunn getting to now
have this big comic book movie yet again
in a very
different way than maybe he thought his
career was was going to go five years
ago and he was unceremoniously fired
from guardians of galaxy 3 for old
tweets that surfaced and now he's back
doing this suicide squad movie and i
will say look the guy knocked guardians
of the galaxy out of the park he's got a
in my opinion a great sense of humor on
screen and i think that this movie has a
lot of potential in his hands with this
cast some of whom is returning from
suicide squad 2016. you have margot
robbie back i believe
joel kinnaman and giant courtney are
back viola davis is back as amanda
waller and so there is some some
familiarity with this movie are we
excited about it start with you roxy and
do you like that they're bringing some
of the characters back from david a or
suicide squad
so i've seen this and i i have i've seen
this yeah okay
so am i excited about it
that's what that's my
that went on today that sounded good no
here's here's what i'm gonna say i just
talked to you guys for an hour about a
movie that i love so are you gonna take
my advice on how i feel about this movie
i love this movie obviously i love this
movie do you think i wasn't gonna like
the the suicide squad in what world it
was freaking awesome okay what's the
biggest difference then between suicide
squad 2016 and the suicide squad 2021
what's the one thing that you're like oh
that is very different is it a tone is
it a flow is it less music what what is
the the big difference i think that they
definitely course corrected on this one
especially story-wise
okay the weakest part of the of suicide
squad
was
what
is the story arc the and that's very
strong in this next one so i think that
the people
and and the villain and the main villain
as well i think that this was very not
similar to the first one in a lot of
ways in tone
it is a little more similar just because
the suicide squad is always going to be
a motley crew of characters that we
are somewhere on the anti-hero
kind of hero kind of villain spectrum so
if you i can't imagine anybody liking
suicide squad and not liking the suicide
squad i'm curious for all the people who
didn't like suicide squad how they're
going to feel although from what we're
seeing based on twitterverse
this movie is getting
a thumbs up across the board from
everybody so
i did see a lot of it so far let's feel
are we going to see this opening night
are we excited
uh it's going to be on hbo max right
i i may uh are you going to wait jackson
play
look okay like i don't think i really
even told the full story suicide squad
broke up me in dc
me and dc
the very first comic book i purchased
was death in the family because i went
to my second grade class and somebody
told me that robin was dead because i
used to come home every single day and
watch batman the animated series and
this dude in my class his name was nick
he was an artist and i was like oh my
god i love me some batman and robin and
this and he was like yeah you know
robin's dead right like that kid that
tells you santa claus doesn't exist and
so my love of batman and dc has like
completely gone on through then and it
was like with when burton did his it was
like young love and then when we got to
stupid robin and batman and robin it was
like oh he cheated on me and this is not
good but then we got christopher nolan's
arc and it was like oh my god we're back
and we're back in love and then this
movie was like he cheated with my sister
i was done i was done with this
franchise i was done with their live
actions i will stick on the animated
form so no this movie broke me and so i
just cannot put any more emotional
investment into these characters because
they have they've hurt me too many times
i think we need to get nick on the phone
and see what he thinks about this one
you should call him and tell him but he
was in mrs carrillo's
class at uh
uh oh god club estates in corpus christi
texas and he told me that robin was dead
and i literally was like you've broken
my soul i'm not a fan of this nick kid
you don't do that to another kid
go tweet spoilers at him from every
movie ever do you know this person's
dead how about this person
yeah hey nick did you see the sixth
sense i got a surprise for you i mean
it made me go to maybe go to a comic
book store for the first time yeah i
remember kids telling me that superman
was gonna die that's uh that's that's me
dating myself uh lucy let's let's wrap
this up with you as well i mean we have
james gunn doing the suicide squad i
know i asked you at the top of the show
are you going with me to see you because
i want to see this movie in a theater i
i
i think that even though i was
disappointed by the first one i am
curious to see what this one does
differently roxy has sold me that it
does enough different things to give it
a clean slate in my mind so jaclyn's
gonna watch it on the small screen which
i've been to jacqueline's place she's a
giant tv she's gonna have a great time
i want to see it on the big on the
biggest screen possible so i think i'm
going to the movies
i'm going with you i'll buy i'll buy
i'll smuggle the treats in
don't no no i know you're a mom and i
know that that's like a mom thing to do
but no i want to wait in line happily do
so and i will if you want to sneak candy
and that's fine yeah i am buying a a hot
fresh tub of popcorn at the theater yes
delicious i'm super excited to see the
shark character
is he voiced by sly stallone sylvester
is that a spoiler oh my god sylvester
stallone does the voice of
now now wait yeah you got to see the
movie to figure out how to pronounce it
it works it's going to be good cena
idris albert sharks a new dishover i
mean what more do you want out of this
movie that's all i want what's what's
gonna be enjoyable for uh for us here on
the show is that roxy brought up the
term motley crew a number of times i did
listen to kickstart my heart at my
workout at 5 00 a.m this morning whoa
they get us up early here at rotten
tomatoes so i had to work out extra
early that leads in to
kind of a trivia question about another
rock star that we're going to get to in
just a sec but right now mr brian perez
our esteemed engineer it's time for
mailbag
[Music]
we love when our ketchup crew emails us
y'all can email us anytime rt is wrong
at
rottentomatoes.com that's rt is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com and this is from
esteemed ketchup crew member mckenna
callahan
and the movie in question is memoirs of
a geisha she says hi friends i've
honestly been pissed about this for
years i know that memoirs of a geisha
wasn't perfectly executed with the
biggest great for most people being the
casting controversy however the film is
absolutely beautiful oscar-winning
cinematography and so well performed
gong lee is a goddess it should not have
a 35
rating on the tomato meter there are
much movies that have higher ratings
even some you've already covered on the
podcast i can go deeper into my
reasoning if you're interested but i
wanted to make sure this was on your
radar thanks no thank you mechanic
callahan that was a a great and
impassioned and you made me say a swear
so a nickel goes in the jar but it was
worth it because you're clearly in love
with memoirs of a geisha i've never seen
this movie my history with this movie is
limited to
king kong was out at the same time and i
remember talking to my brother on the
phone because him and his then
girlfriend who's now his wife were going
to the movies and he said that they went
to go see memoirs of a geisha and i'm
like robbie you got to take control this
related king kong is is at the movies
and you're going to see memoirs robbie
it's king kong so i was mad at my
brother for giving in to his wife's
wishes
and clearly it worked out for him okay
anybody care about memoirs of a geisha
anybody have feelings
i mean
i just remember the controversy with
madonna wanting to play that character i
remember very little about that movie no
so i think this is like legit unless my
brain is playing tricks on me madonna
lobbied like very heavily to play the
lead character in memoirs of a geisha
and then actually shot a music video
like her like kimono look that she did
in one of her music videos was
essentially her
so that is like the most interesting
thing i can think about that one because
i barely remember that movie but i would
talk about it scarjo was so excited by
that she did the same thing for the rest
of her career
i have
i have so little i know i saw this when
i was
in high school i have so little memory
of this one way or another that it must
not have
neither moved me nor
upset me i think that
worth a re-watch uh and if y'all want to
talk about it then that then hello here
i am i would love to rewatch this rob
marshall directed memoirs of a geisha he
did wha what was that about
i'll check it out oh my god
here look i'm seeing i'm at my brother's
place right now i will make a deal with
my brother he has to watch peter
jackson's king kong and i'll put on
memories of a geisha my movie's gonna be
finished first i know that my movie's
ending before peter jackson's king kong
ends
peter jackson's king kong is actually a
pretty good movie though i will say this
it is a pretty good movie it got it got
a bad rap it did it's funny but yeah
it's very very good and speaking of good
movies somebody on this show today is
gonna go make a great one we have full
confidence in her that is the one the
only roxie strea roxy it was a delight
tell us how much you can about this
upcoming film project i you and i have
been friends for a long time and i am
just so excited to see hard work pay off
see she brought it back
i'm gonna be in a movie i'm really
excited about this we are going to film
on location for the next several weeks
it's uh i feel confident talking about
it because it's on my imdb so i feel
like that means that i'm allowed to say
it's called always lola i'm lola uh and
so i you're the title of the movie yeah
i am the mark i've been waiting my whole
life to say this i am the titular
character
damn right you
like and i have to say i first read this
script
three years ago
and it has my whole heart it's really
it's it is a beautiful indie
um
letter
i feel like it's a love letter um from
the writer to uh to a friend and it is
it's really good it's really really
effing good so i'm
more than excited to do it
i'm certainly not sleeping these days in
preparation and when i come back here
afterwards i'll let you guys know how it
went
okay top three animals live or dead that
you want jacqueline and i to send you
while you're on set to help us get into
character if you could find a unicorn
then you can
then you can kill it and send it to me
wow okay we're killing unicorns here on
this show um before we let you get out
of here roxy do you have a good
streaming recommendation for the kids at
home i know you're a huge tv fan you're
a tv expert so if you want to go in that
world that is totally cool so i'm gonna
tell you guys about a show that i
honestly am not sure if you've ever
heard of this is something that i binged
about a year ago and in that time i feel
like nobody's listened to me and i i
need somebody to listen to me so here is
here's the the show
it's called how to sell drugs online
fast
that is a real title of the show it's on
netflix it's dubbed i think that it was
a
i think that it was a german show and
it's dubbed here now i watch the dub
version because i can't it's it they
move really fast because we're talking
about drugs so i
i needed to not just have subtitles
because so it's so fast but i hear that
it's even better if you can do the
subtitle version
this show is awesome i don't know why
it's not more talked about it's one of
those netflix things that got totally
buried and the reason i'm bringing it up
today is because
it's not the same as suicide squad at
all but if you like things that are like
what the f is happening right now what
is going on here this is definitely that
show it has three seasons so there's
enough for you to really chew on
and it's it's really it's really really
really stellar
the acting is incredible the storyline
is bonkers it's about somebody who needs
to make money and
start selling drugs online fast and
just everything that happens is it's an
awesome show i i need netflix to promote
it more because that's somebody please
listen to me i have no one to talk to
about it and it's based on a real story
that's just actual real story yeah like
this dude literally did become one of
the most prolific drug dealers online
for life jaclyn are you watching
no i watched the documentary
that eventually inspired that show so i
didn't watch the show but i watched the
doc that um inspired it and yeah yeah
everybody needs a dream out there so
have at it kids all right i did promise
a a quick trivia question about a
rockstar so david ayer's very first
screenwriting credit is u571 the
submarine movie roxy i know you hate
hate hate when i ask you trivia so i'm
gonna give you an easy phone at jaclyn
if you need to okay but what
famous rock star
plays one of the crew of the submarine
who unceremoniously gets his face point
off about halfway into the movie
in
u571 yeah you five seven one huge huge
rock star is that the mcconaughey thing
uh mcconaughey isn't it yes sir
what year are we talking mark mid 90s
like late 1996-97
what huge rock star huge rock star i
mean he was living
on a prayer
yes yes yes
roxy strong the rock star
it's it's it's bon jon bonjon yeah john
bon jovi close enough we can give you
credit for actually getting enough i'm
nicknamed my man
close enough john bonfire guess mick
jagger so i was really far off he was
great in free jack what happens to bon
jon jon bon jovi he gets his face blown
off
yeah they all die
yeah he meets like the wrong end of like
a cannonballer so it's it's not pretty
so he's been in young guns too where he
eats it and he also eats it in u571 i
think he survived uh romeo's bleeding
though so
good or not romeo's bleed ah we'll we'll
figure it out in the next episode of the
show we gotta wrap things up but roxy it
has been so great having you here um
thank you again so much good luck on set
we know you're gonna crush it and uh you
have our full support cannot wait to
check out the movie where you play the
titular character as for us here on the
show jaclyn we always love when folks
email us as we said you can subscribe to
this show rate review do all those
things wherever you enjoy listening to
this podcast thanks for watching us on
any one of our platforms and how about
it for grandpa's jersey devil pretty
cool look huh thank you to everybody for
listening to the show for watching the
show thanks to the hard working team
here at rotten tomatoes for making a
sound and look good every week that
would be engineer brian perez producey
lucy our esteemed guest roxy stryer
thanks for being on the show while you
know you're you're still not
giving an oscar receptive if you want to
mention us in the oscar acceptance
speech you're more than welcome to
yes we will accept that that is roxy my
co-host jacqueline coley
i'm just mark ellis thanks for listening
and we'll tune in to you all when you
tune in to us next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you